this is amazing to me
number one it's amazing to me it's not a
bigger deal that aaron rodgers and tom
brady are getting together this weekend
i mean there's so much else going on in
the nfl this doesn't really stand out
and it's weird because it's the
buccaneers we still can't get used to
that
37 combined years of nfl experience for
tom brady and aaron rodgers and they've
only ever played each other twice
in their careers
aaron rodgers won in 2014.
tom brady got his revenge in 2018
and now it's not really the rubber match
because they may meet again they can
meet in the playoffs they can meet next
year as long as they're in the same
conference it's a lot easier to cross
paths but amazing this is only going to
be the third time two of the greatest of
all time get together peter
and you know mike that's one of the
reasons why
uh
you know look it's impossible to fix the
schedule
so that things like this you know
uh are avoided but there was a time
where dan marino and john elway didn't
play each other for like
eight or nine years in a row and they
were in the same conference
um but i think the one thing about this
matchup that is so much fun
is just the simple prospect
that
it's two guys playing even though you
might laugh at this saying i mean
tom brady is not necessarily at his peak
but he has shown this year
that he could have peak perform a peak
performance aaron rodgers is playing at
his peak
and what is so impressive about those
numbers on the left hand side i went
back last week it's going to be in my
column on monday i went back last week
and looked at the starts of seasons his
mvp seasons
you know for aaron rodgers versus his
two mvp seasons and this is
this start to the season is better than
either one and so
you say to yourself okay
why'd they draft jordan love now i mean
you know what what was the reason of
bypassing one of the richest
uh crops of receivers in nfl draft
history
i mean i'd still look
what's done is done
but that is still one of the most
curious things i've not that
you not that you get your quarterback in
the future truly i don't think that's
outrageous when a guy's 35 years old and
you pick a quarterback that's not
outrageous what's outrageous at least to
me and and it hasn't come home to roost
at all so i'm wrong but what's
outrageous to me is that they bypassed
the receiver not just in the first round
in the draft
yeah and look it's not just using the
first round pick on jordan love it's
throwing in the fourth round pick so
they could move up higher to get him
that fourth round pick could have been a
receiver in a receiver-rich draft like
this was and i i still
have this theory that mark murphy the
ceo of the packers who's been more
involved in the football operations in
recent years
i think that
he saw
a way
to
piss aaron rodgers off a little bit to
make him even better this year
and that was a way to do it and it's a
hedge against the future you don't know
how much longer he's going to be able to
play we like what jordan love can do
there's potential there and if it gets
aaron rodgers riled up just like the
report from tyler dunn last year when he
was with bleacher report that delved
into the aaron rodgers mike mccarthy
dysfunction i remember murphy saying in
the aftermath you know what this could
be good if it makes some people upset
this could be good so he's got that
capacity in his brain and my guess would
be privately
when everything went down in late april
he said to somebody with the packers
probably gm brian goodikoons do you know
what if this gets aaron upset and
focused and motivated it could be good
well mike i'll tell you i talked to
brian gudekunst on sunday of that draft
weekend i wrote this in my post draft
column
he said
if the result of us taking jordan love
means that we're going to get four great
years out of aaron rodgers well that's
great then we the goal here
is to make sure
that we continue
this great quarterback tradition brett
favre
aaron rodgers now jordan love so the
goal is to do that
and if we do that by the veteran playing
great for the next four years and he
didn't say this these are my words and
if they have to jimmy garoppolo
jordan love you know and say trade him
either in his last contractual year or
prior to that hey that's fine
and i you know okay i get that
and it's logical and hey look i am not
trying to recreate history right now i'm
just simply saying
the ultimate head scratcher of the 2020
nfl draft always will be
that the green bay packers did not take
a wide receiver
that's that's
you mentioned jimmy garoppolo and you
take it back to 2014 think about where
the patriots were entering the 2014
season the year they used a second round
pick on garoppolo they hadn't won a
super bowl in 10 years
and that garoppolo
knife in the back of tom brady and i
think he reacted to it in a negative way
and it made him very determined and
focused and what happened they won three
more super bowls before tom brady left
so to the extent that that quarterback
draft pick in round one or two is part
insurance policy but also part let's
motivate the guy that we have to get the
best out of him before he's done for
good
the results are there from the new
england patriots and they may be there
from the green bay packers and look you
know
this game is fascinating because of the
fact that the buccaneers lost last
thursday night they go into this game
four and one okay they can get away with
this one all right you know the pack
yeah okay
they lose this when they fall to three
and three
desperation time begins kind of sort of
for the buccaneers no one expected them
to be three and three tom brady doesn't
go three and three
uh and i think they're gonna have their
hands full with green bay especially
since green bay had two full weeks to
get ready for this one peter
no question about it i'm gonna say one
more quick thing about about garoppolo
because and how it relates to jordan
love the new england patriots played
that absolutely perfectly
other than the fact they probably could
have gotten more for garoppolo if they
put them on the open market than they
got from san francisco but good for bill
belichick he traded him somewhere where
he knew he'd be coached well he'd have a
really good chance to win and so they
didn't get a one for him but
how great did the patriots do in playing
up the value of jimmy garoppolo you know
started two games for him was really
good in both
one both starts never threw an
interception as a patriot accurate
quarterback and so again they could do
the same thing with jordan love about
this weekend's game the thing that
interests me the most about this game
is
how tom brady comes back from an
ignominious game okay you know that
aaron rodgers is going to be joe cool
he's going to play great he's not going
to beat himself okay tom brady has to
come out he knows this he has to come
out he's had a little extra time to
think about it and his receivers know
that and whoever they are because
they've been playing basically the
practice squad you know they had to play
some of those guys uh you know against
chicago
he knows coming into this game that
there's this narrative about him hey
maybe brady's slipping a little bit so
it's just another bit of motivation for
brady to quote stick it to the man you
know stick it to the fan and and i think
that's going to work well in brady's
favor at 4 30 sunday afternoon
well the one thing we need to keep in
mind despite everything that we said
about brady losing track of the downs
and what anyone else would say how fans
react everybody knew he lost track of
the downs
the fact that they were so stubborn and
they refused to admit it i just wonder
how the locker room reacts what kind of
what kind of side-eye looks he's gotten
from folks this week as it comes off as
his ego being too big to even admit that
he made a mistake and and does it cause
anyone in that locker room to view him
just a little bit differently even if
they won't say it they view them just a
little bit differently and and do they
view their head coach a little bit
differently who cusses out everyone
for
multiple times taking up for tom brady
and saying that yes he knew it was
fourth down even though anyone with eyes
who was watching that game
you know the one thing mike that when i
look at
this game
other than just the quarterbacks okay
this is the game that the tampa bay
buccaneers need to have their weaponry
peter okay and this is the game they
really need to have a guy like they need
to have their receivers back and mike
you're back but one of the points i was
just making is that
if
if tom brady doesn't have full health in
his receiving core you know against a
team like green bay and green bay you
know is going to put up 30.
that that that this is the kind of game
that you need to have depth and depth of
targets for tom brady to be able to win
this game
i had a quick power outage i knew it
when it happened and i just kept talking
in the unlikely event that anyone could
hear me and i tried not to say any curse
words as i realized that i had a quick
power outage but i am back and thank you
peter for picking up the baton and
running with it i i i have yet to
mention that this is the game
that chris berman used to call the bay
of pigs and i guess we call it the bay
of goats weekend i don't know
but you know and it was a it was a
well-earned nickname for this game
because back in the 80s both of these
teams were horrendous and they were both
in the nfc central and there were years
where they were like one would be three
and 13 and the other would be two and 14
even though they got to play each other
twice that's basically where they got
their wins and everybody else pummeled
them back in those days all right the
browns are a team that everyone has
pummeled in recent years from 2015 to
2017 they were four and 44. this year
they're four and one and they're
bringing a different vibe than they've
had in years into heinz field to take on
the pittsburgh steelers peter this game
is fascinating to me in so many ways
pittsburgh is undefeated for the first
time since 1979 at 4-0 but you look at
their games look at who they've played
look at how they've won it has not been
impressive they have dilly-dallied with
some bad teams the giants pushed them
until late in the third quarter even
though the steelers ultimately won by 10
it was not a 10-point game until
the the hit on daniel jones by bud
dupree pops the ball into the air and
ends a drive that could have put the
giants ahead going into the fourth
quarter the game against the broncos
denver was in position to try to win it
late the game against the texans the the
texans were up 14-3 and they had a lead
later in the game as well
the the eagles gave the steelers
everything they could handle and none of
these teams are playoff contenders so
i just i now that the steelers in week
five are finally facing a contender this
year and it's the browns a team that
they've been able to take for granted
for 20 years
i just i i can't wait to see how this
steelers team matches up with a team
that they've been able to look down
their noses at that all of a sudden is
the best team they've seen so far this
year
you know i was talking to bill cower
yesterday mike um about sort of this
rivalry and and you may recall i mean
bill cower
from pittsburgh he grew up four miles
from three rivers stadium slash heinz
field
uh grew up a gigantic steeler fan he
goes away to college at north carolina
state then he ends up sticking with the
browns as a free undrafted free agent
linebacker special teamer
and he goes and he and he comes home to
play the pittsburgh steelers as a member
of the browns and he's just so emotional
he can't believe he's standing on the
field and look over there there's mike
webster oh my god but but anyway
one of the points that cower made to me
was at that time
the rivalry was so intense
and was so
passionate
because of things like the turkey jones
throw down of terry bradshaw
and the both teams were good
and and the and the browns even though
the steelers were winning super bowls
the browns could knock them off you know
because they had a good team too
but
and and and i agree with cower i said to
him this is really about the first time
in 25 years maybe longer than that that
both of these teams this far into the
season you could say hey they really
might be good and he said it's so good
for football
to have the browns and the steelers and
that sort of rust belt rivalry you know
the uh the the turnpike rivalry between
pittsburgh and cleveland
and mike i just think this is one of
those things in a very weird year this
game kind of sneaks up on us
but
raven steelers has taken over as the big
rivalry you know in that area of the
country and in that part of the league
but it would be so good for football
if the browns were good for a while and
the brown steelers became a national tv
game again
well at a time when raiders chiefs may
be rediscovering what once was a great
rivalry and hasn't been in recent years
because the raiders have been so bad
since their super bowl appearance
and you know the the browns did beat the
steelers last year on that thursday
night we forget the outcome of the game
because the headline was what miles
garrett did to mason rudolph but but the
steelers didn't have ben roethlisberger
that wasn't the real steelers i mean the
steelers have owned this this rivalry in
recent years in large part because the
browns have been
so bad and uh you know i think the key
for both teams is going to be how much
time will the offensive line by the
quarterback because the defensive front
seven for both teams is so good and you
know we saw last week and i thought the
colts were going to beat the browns joel
betonio held deforest buckner in check
all day long so that cleveland browns
offensive line is going to be able to
protect whoever ends up playing
quarterback whether it's baker mayfield
or case keenum can the steelers
offensive line keep the browns defensive
front seven at bay and buy time for ben
roethlisberger that's really going to be
one of the keys peter
you know and
look i know everybody says that boy
miles garrett what a black eye that was
for the nfl and it was and what a black
guy it was for miles gary and it was
but
and i'm not looking at it affectionately
at all
but i am saying
you know there's a little juice to this
game other than
4-0 against four in one and that is the
subplot of miles garrett trying to keep
him away from
ben roethlisberger and trying to keep
him from wrecking the game all of a
sudden the browns are not just hey let's
watch the browns because they got odell
beckham jr you know
let's watch the browns on defense
because miles garrett has a strip sack
in three straight games you know and and
and he's and he's really wrecked some
games kind of like aaron donald does so
that subplot really interests me in this
game i you know hey look i'm looking
forward to
uh bucks and you know brady and rogers
too don't don't get me wrong but there's
something about this game i will watch
every snap of this game
the uh browns have allowed six sacks
this year the steelers seven
and garrett has six for second in the
league tj watt of the steelers is four
and a half sacks he's fifth in the
league the browns last one in pittsburgh
way back in 2003 that was the year after
these two teams met in the playoffs now
these are the reconstituted browns when
you mentioned the ravens rivalry with
the steelers that's really the browns i
mean the lineage is the browns and i
know ravens fans get upset when you say
that browns fans get upset when you say
it but it's the truth the browns became
the ravens in 1996 and that rivalry has
flourished these these browns were an
expansion team in 1999 they did get to
the playoffs fairly quickly they did
give the steelers everything they could
handle in a shootout game with i think
kelly holcomb at quarterback for crying
out loud and tommy maddox for the
steelers but that's how long it's been
since the browns have been to the
playoffs this browns team since it
returned to the nfl in 1999 won playoff
berth that game in pittsburgh in the
wild card round and you know peter when
you look at the brown schedule we may be
able to put it up here
there are five or six more wins
clearly
on the surface of the schedule the
question is how many more than that can
they get but this team is destined to be
in the mix for a wild card berth and
look they may not win the division title
i mean they got blown off the field by
the ravens but they get another shot at
them coming up later in the year week
14. but there are plenty of games you
can look at and say there's a win
there's a win there's a win there's a
win all the way to 10 wins for the first
time in a very long time
you know it isn't only that mike it's
it's the way they're playing there's an
explosiveness to this offense that
simply hasn't been there
and one of the things i really like too
about kevin stefanski
is
you know
he's he's one of these guys kevin
stefanski and matt rule are incredibly
alike
in this one regard
and that is that they both basically
uh
they
they basically are from the chuck noll
school
of
the only thing in your life that matters
the only thing
is what happens this sunday that's it
nothing else we don't care about the
schedule down the road we don't care
about this we don't care we care about
what's the best team and what's the best
game plan we can use this week
in in within three or four days of each
other i talked to both guys both rule
and stefanski stefanski must have said
that to me in some form five times in 20
minutes it was and
you know and at the end i said okay i
get it i get it but it's just the way he
feels and so i think that's why
they look at this game
as exactly as they're going to look at
when they play the bengals
which is
this is the championship game of this
week and i think they're going to figure
out a way to be explosive
good on the browns for not allowing the
nick chubb injury to really derail them
because mike what they have done with de
ernest johnson you know the undrafted
guy from south florida who nobody ever
heard of and he comes in the game two
weeks ago in dallas and he's he's
awesome
and you know you basically you look at
this team right now and you basically
say
they are a real threat this is not this
is something that is built to last so
that's the first time you've been able
to say that about the browns in a while
yeah and you know for as dysfunctional
as it all was in the aftermath of week
one when it felt like it was going to be
just like last year with all the talk
about how often is odell beckham jr
getting the ball does he really need to
be there i was a firm believer they
should trade him they found a way to
make it work and now when you're winning
it works
but kevin stefanski has gotten him to
buy in his role is going to change week
in and week out it's going to be driven
like you said by the matchup against the
cowboys it was obj all day against the
cults who were expecting that and who
game plan to take him away they took him
away and it opened up everything else
and you know he didn't have the kind of
impact that he had against the cowboys
and and that's part of the the chess
match that goes on week in and week out
and that's what the great coaches do
it's not just my system my system my
system and i'm going to use my system no
matter what it's what can i do to
ultimately prevail in this game against
this offense against this defense
whatever it takes and that's one of the
reasons why the browns are on the right
track the chiefs and the bills clearly
on the right track although not recently
i'll tell you what this early monday
night game got a lot more interesting
when the bills got blown out by the
titans and when the chiefs lost to the
raiders because now there's urgency that
wouldn't have been there if both of
these teams are 5-0 oh hey this is a
battle of unbeatens but whoever loses is
still feeling pretty good whoever loses
this one
may be feeling not so good because to go
from four and over four and two
it may make you a little bit concerned
about where you really are peter
for some reason mike i view this game as
being a little bit more important for
buffalo
um
and and i'll give you two reasons why
number one they
they were riding such a high going into
tennessee
and then basically a team that hadn't
had
a real practice
for 17 days
uh you know since two and a half weeks
ago friday
um
you know the the titans just manhandled
the buffalo bills
and so your buffalo and all of a sudden
you say man you know that really was a
punch in the jaw but it isn't just for
the team to me it was for the
quarterback uh because josh allen
basically looked like
josh allen of 2018.
um he it looked like he got shook up a
little bit
and and look
his first interception that went right
through andre roberts hands i'll blame
josh allen mostly for that because it
was so far behind
andre roberts but the fact is that was a
poor throw roberts probably should have
had it but it was a poor throw and it
was intercepted
that's the time when you need to sort of
settle and you need to say okay we're
going to be all right it's fluky play
it's one play
and it just never really got
consistently better
and so
josh allen now has his second huge game
in a row
second huge national tv game in a row
and all of a sudden now there's going to
be a little bit more focus on him he's
gone from being one of the mvp front
runners to
is what we saw in the first month of
mirage and i don't think it was
but he's got to play better in this game
i think to to sort of assuage all doubts
uh about his performance in tennessee
yeah i think what you're saying is this
peter the chiefs know who they are
patrick mahomes knows who he is the
bills are in the process of finding out
who they are what they are what josh
allen is and based on the first four
weeks of the season
they thought we thought everyone thought
that this was one of those dramatic
jumps that this is a team that could
potentially have a special season a team
of destiny all the cliches you hear when
there's a team that just shows up and
starts pummeling everyone and they can
handle all comers and they just win and
win and win and win
you lay an egg or something else like
they laid on tuesday night against the
titans and it makes everyone wonder is
this team
really that good you know i'll say from
time to time that especially in prime
time for playoff contenders if you lose
in really convincing fashion it almost
kind of disqualifies you from the
conversation for truly elite teams now
the bill's lost to the titans it's not
like they lost to the jets that way or
like the 49ers getting blown out at home
by the dolphins that's disqualifying for
the 49ers it's not really disqualifying
for the bills
but it does create a lot of a lot of
questions and just a sense of wobbliness
as to where this team is and they got
the chiefs coming to town who are going
to be fully focused that's the thing
about the chiefs you never know what
they're going to do
when
you don't have their full attention but
when you do have their full attention
it's what happened to the ravens a
couple of weeks ago on monday night and
i feel like that's what's gonna happen
to the bills this monday night
you know i i don't get a great feel for
this game because you know one of the
things you saw with the raiders is that
tell you what speed can really a speed
can kill anybody the the chiefs have
been showing that for the last couple of
years
but i'll tell you speed really hurt uh
the kansas city defense
against the raiders and when i look at
that game i watched a lot of that game
i really now see exactly why john gruden
was fixated on henry ruggs because
he he really confounds a defense
because he makes you i don't want to
even say nervous about it but you know
that if you make one mistake
it's it's not fixable because if he
catches a ball and he's got two steps on
you it's impossible to catch him
so
that's why to me
this game i'm not positive because look
stefan diggs has been a big impact
player and he doesn't have the speed
necessarily obviously of henry ruggs but
he's been a huge impact player and
stefan diggs down field and mike what
about uh what about john brown in this
game do we know about john brown
i haven't seen where he is yeah they
didn't have john brown or davia's white
on tuesday night and look they got the
extra day to turn it around thursday
would have been their first injury
report i'll pull it up and take a look
at it but um
you're right they need that they need to
have everyone healthy to have a chance
they need tredavius white to help out
with tyree killing company and they need
john brown and you know the the chiefs
aren't going to have uh sammy watkins
but this is where that that genius that
is
andy reid kicks in where hey i got me
cole hardman and he'll step in and he'll
get it done and uh and they won't miss
sammy watkins the way they would have so
uh there's a lot of depth there there's
a lot of quality there and they have
patrick mahomes here's mahomes talking
about
the need to bounce back after what
happened to them on sunday at home
against the raiders
we just didn't execute and play to the
level and the efficiency that we're used
to playing at um and when you play
against another team that's a great
opponent and you're not executing at a
high level and putting your defense in
in bad situations uh usually you usually
don't win the football game and so uh we
understand that and know that we can't
just rely on the big play we got to make
sure that we execute at a high level and
when the big play comes we have to find
a way to hit it and win the football
game
john brown fully participated in
practice on thursday with a knee injury
one thing that stands out to me josh
allen has a left shoulder injury that i
think it dates back to a couple of weeks
ago it was against the raiders i think
that scared us he fully participated in
practice anytime there's a quarterback
injury though i lock in on that so it
looks good for him
uh trinavius white limited in practice
with a back injury so the bills may be
getting those two guys back brown and
white and they need both of them if they
want to have a chance against the chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports